pensé que era el Apocalipsis Tratamos de
salir pero no pudimos sentimos que la
casa se derrumbaba los niños también
estaban allí yo dije corran a las
esquinas escondanse hijos pero no
pudimos escapar
nos desplomamos frente a la puerta
es una de las supervivientes del
terremoto que azotó a Turquía el 6 de
febrero ahora desde un hospital de
Estambul relata como vivió varios días
bajo los escombros del apartamento en el
que residía el sismo se cobró la vida de
su esposo y sus dos hijos
estaba hablando con mi esposo él estaba
vivo pero no podía escuchar a los niños
mi esposo murió al segundo día
en el mismo hospital se recupera en
minecadioglu una mujer de 84 años que
también fue rescatada de los escombros
sus gritos fueron escuchados desde
dentro de las ruinas
una voz me llamó Hay alguien ahí me
estoy moviendo Hay alguien ahí cuando vi
la voz dije querido quién eres estoy
aquí quién eres la voz dijo ven aquí
abuelita y yo dije no puedo ir tengo la
pierna rota no puedo ir después de decir
eso vino el chico y no recuerdo si me
bajaron con una sola persona o con dos
esa parte no la recuerdo
después del rescate el peligro continúa
los médicos deben hacer seguimiento a lo
que denominan como síndrome de
aplastamiento que puede causar entre
otras insuficiencias renal las labores
de búsqueda terminaron en gran parte de
Turquía con los hospitales atestados el
terremoto ya se ha cobrado la vida de
decenas de miles de personas